yo what's up guys my name is Samuel
Leeds on a property investor and I
really enjoy helping other property
investors on their journey so if you are
an aspiring property investor or already
investing in property right now I'm
gonna do a Q&A I do this every single
Sunday so let's have a look at some of
the questions from the last Sunday video
and while I'm speaking if you have
questions that you want me to answer
comment them below in this video and
next week I'll do my best to try to
answer as many as I can so let's see
what we got can you explain sourcing in
detail legally and processes etc and
also how old do I have to be to source
in a nutshell property sourcing I assume
you're talking about deal packaging okay
which is when you source a property and
then you pass it on to an investor for a
fee that's what it is I did this when I
was like 17 18 years old I'll just find
houses for people and then they would
pay me a fee I think that every property
investor should be a deal packager as
well because the thing is if you're out
looking for houses for yourself
sometimes you're gonna come across deals
that don't work for you
maybe the deal is too expensive or maybe
you've already you've just found a deal
and you've just offered on it and
secured it and then as it happens you
find another deal in the same day it's
like waiting for a bus you know you're
waiting for probably almost only two or
three come at once
or maybe the deal just isn't in your
patch or doesn't fit your strategy and
this is gonna happen to you all the time
so my suggestion is look for properties
for yourself but then when you come
across those other ones that are really
good but just don't quite work for you
pass them to your network and charge a
fee it just it's just obvious and then
the money that you make from that you'll
be able to put them towards buying more
deals for yourself so I think everybody
should be a deal sorcerer also if you're
just starting out and you have got the
knowledge and the skills we don't have
any money it's a really good way because
ultimately an average property that you
pass on to somebody for a fee it might
make you 2 or 3 grand which means that
if you pass one property to somebody
once a month then you've replaced a
full-time salary so it's a really good
way to replace the salary I just I love
deal packaging so legally what are the
legalities of it so if your packaging
deals and selling them to an investor
you do need to be compliant
and what that entails is it entails you
know insurance you need to be part of a
redress scheme if something goes wrong
you need terms and conditions you know
there are things that you need so what I
would suggest is I'm really the link
below with a an Amazon link to
Alistair's book Alastair Cunningham
wrote a book called whatever it takes
and in that there's a chapter which is
dedicated towards how to become
compliant as a deal saucer so I'll leave
a link in the book it looks a really
good book anyway so that's the gist the
process is find a house negotiate it
once you've had an offer accepted you
then find an investor and then you
invoice the investor maybe get him to
sign an NDA a nondisclosure agreement so
that you can look at the property and he
can check do his due diligence on it and
whatever if the investor wants to go
ahead they pay you a fee that's how it
works
really simple anyway hope that helps
what else we got thanks for the great
content question how would you advise
scaling up in property starting from
just single debts and HMOs and
eventually apartment blocks and serviced
office blocks okay so you'll always
screw up on your first deal so if you're
wanting to scale and go big what I'd say
is I'd much rather screw up on a small
deal than on a big deal just start small
like you've said just start with a
little single in maybe and then once
you've done that you've got some
experience go a little bit bigger and a
little bit bigger but ultimately if you
want to scale my suggestion is to use
other people's money to joint venture
with other people because if you're if
you're always using your own money for
deals then it's just going to be such a
slow process and if you want to scale
big all of the guys that are scaling big
like Robert Kiyosaki he scaled a massive
Grant Cardone
scaled a massive me I'm scaling massive
and we all do it by joint venture with
people partnerships using other people's
money but the only way you're going to
have to do that is by becoming really
good first and getting really a lot of
experience so that's my advice
Michael says how would you go about
finding a hundred thousand pound for a
flat then renting it out and refinancing
it is it really that simple it is really
that simple if you know how to do it
you're not gonna get a hundred thousand
pound if you don't know how to do it so
you're going to you're gonna need to
have the skills of being able to find
the good deal as a property investor the
first thing you need to be able to do is
find good deals but if you're wanting to
get a hundred thousand pound or somebody
a proposal you know like if you're doing
a business plan or something and
following a good deal write a proposal
and set and say to someone look this is
the deal this is what the worth of the
apartment is this is how much I'm gonna
be able to buy it for this is the rent
this is the area this is the expected
capital appreciation this is my due
diligence and then make a proposal so
maybe you want to say I don't know
exactly what you need 100 grand for if
you're looking to raise it but but put
together a proposal and make it really
specific so you put the money in here's
the deal and then we'll go 50/50 on the
profits or I'll give you guaranteed 10
percent we - you know so just be really
specific and be really clear and put
together a clear proposal if you want to
raise money okay do you know if estate
agents take brown paper envelopes from
their developer friends to undersell
properties I'm sure it happens but I
don't think it happens very much estate
agencies do have rules against that the
best way to get good deals from the
state agents is to build rapport be
honest and ultimately to buy from them
once you've bought one deal from an
estate agent they see that you serious
they see that you're a buyer they'll
just bring you all the best stuff they
don't need a brown paper envelope from
you because they get any paid from the
seller the person selling the house so
what they're looking for from you is
they're looking for you to be a serious
buyer someone that can act fast so as
long as you can demonstrate that you
don't need to give them brown paper
envelopes so does it happen maybe but
not in my world of property investing it
does not happen okay band says I'm keen
interests in lease options I was
wondering if you sign the purchase to
the property in five years however when
the time comes to purchase you don't
have the money for whatever reason what
happens to the equity in the property so
a lease option agreement is that easier
sense when you buy a property now but
you pay for it later if after the end of
the five years or however long the term
is if you haven't got the money to buy
it then you have to walk away
unfortunately so you don't get penalized
but you do lose the equity in the
property so you've got to buy it so what
I would say is in that five years all
the rent that you're getting off the
property put it into a pot and save it
and then use that to put down as the
deposit in five years time or raise the
finance or get a frigging loan I don't
know dude but you've got five years to
figure that out so just make sure you
have the money otherwise you're still
benefited from the cash flow but you're
the equity at the end of the term okay
last question what's your favorite app
on your phone
YouTube how could I have enough savings
and hours I'm on YouTube every day
putting videos out I'm also watching the
videos on YouTube every day for
inspiration YouTube probably followed by
my banking app hey guys thanks so much I
hope you found that useful
please do smash that like button if you
enjoyed the video if you're not
subscribed subscribe and if you've got
questions posted below or do my best to
answer if you'd like to see something
Williams really really really really
really inspiring I went and moved into
someone's house for a week
I made him financially free in one week
if you haven't seen that video it's an
hour and a half so scheduled to watch it
but it's right here and if you want to
come down to the property investors
crash course is a free two-day program
on the house you can get a free ticket
right here limited availability to them
right now and of course subscribe if you
haven't already right here thanks so
much I'll see you next week